Remember I said, processes or
programs execute an address space.
It's a linear address space.
It goes from zero to
some maximum address,
depending on what your
address space size is.
And a little bit more complicated,
we'll get to that when we
talk about operating systems.
Part of the address space is where
the operating system goes, but
the other part is where user code and
data is going to go.
So that's the part we're talking about.
There's some place where the code is
going to go, that's called segment,
that long lived data goes into part of
that other space that's called the heap.
And the temporary or dynamically
allocated data that we were just talking
about, when you make function calls,
goes into the stack.
That's what the stack is used for.
So we know a stack is,
basically the two things you can do
with the stack is push things on it.
So there's a stack pointer.
When you push something that
is put on top of the stack and
the stack pointer moves one place.
The other thing you can do with
a stack is pop something off it.
So when you do a pop operation,
then the data item or
the element that is at the top of the
stack, the stack pointer it's pointing
to, actually gets popped off,
put in some other place, a register or
a memory location
different from the stack.
And then the stack
pointer is adjusted to
reflect the fact that that
item is no longer there.
So if you sort of think about
the stack as you do push and pop,
the stack pointer moves.
And you need to sort of see in
what direction the stack grows.
So when you push things onto the stack,
the stack is growing.
You're adding more items to it.
When you pop things off,
the stack its shrinking, and
the stack pointer moves as
the stack grows or shrinks.
So we are going to assume that the stack
actually grows from high addresses
to low addresses.
So the stack pointer
starts at some address.
And remember that address space starts
at zero and goes to the maximum so
we have this increasing addresses,
address n, n plus 1, n plus 2.
Typically it is byte addressable,
so each unit for
which we have an address is a byte,
or eight bits.
So the addresses increase as
we go down the address space.
So when I say the stack is going from
high addresses to low addresses,
what does that mean?
Well, the stack pointer actually
absolute address value,
it's going to decrease as we
push things onto the stack.
We allocated some amount of room for
the stack, or some amount of space for
the stack and grow and shrink.
And the stack pointer is initialized
to the bottom of that space.
So the highest address that we have for
the stack reason.
And as we push things onto the stack,
the stack moves to a lower address.